There are many other applications of
dynamic programming that we haven't
touched on, but the three we
covered provide a good sample and
help illustrate the general strategy.
Perhaps the most important lesson, is
that any time you've found a recursive
solution to a problem, think carefully
about what the subproblems are and
whether there's an overlap
that you can exploit.
Note that this won't always work.
Dynamic program will not yield
a polynomial algorithm for
every problem with
a recursive formulation.
Take satisfiability, for example.
Pick a variable and set it to true, and
eliminate the variable from
the rest of the formula.
We're left with another Boolean formula.
And if it's satisfiable,
then so is the original.
The same is true if we set
the variable to false.
And the original formula will
have a satisfying assignment
if either of these other formulas do.
This is a perfectly legitimate
recursive formulation, yet
there isn't enough overlap between
the subproblems to create a polynomial
algorithm, at least not
unless p is equal to np.
In the next lesson, we'll examine
the fast Fourier transform.
This is much more a divide and
conquer problem,
than it is a dynamic programming one.
Though many of the same themes
of identifying subproblems and
reusing calculation will
appear as we study it.
Keep this in mind.